And now again, this is Dr. Connor section 19 year coming to the clothes in the book the section is smaller
The next section is a little bigger. So this section, we talk about some common
complications that we see when people come to us understand both patients
And in fact, I don't can't remember a patient that's come to us that just turned they have cancer and they want to do an alternative
Approach just typically doesn't happen
They stand in our office. We get patients that have done chemo radiation surgery
Are in stage 4 have been given you know two weeks to two months to five months to live
Have been told to go home and get their fares in order and they call us
It's just the way it goes
And that's okay. So it's some it's a blessing when you see miracles happen and we see miracles
Pretty regular basis, and that's what keeps us going. So I love it
There are a lot of complications what you're dealing with especially with somebody who's done chemo
Radiation surgery and has kind of fumbled through ways to stimulate an immune response and to help them get through that
Situation you go in most chemo wards, and they have a refrigerator with refreshments and it's you know gain a rated
juicing and
and sweetened milk and
Ensure and that's their idea of nutrition. It's it's hilarious
I had a patient to
Squat through chemo that sent me pictures of what they were given as treats they're given cookies and stack cakes and
To deal with the with the feeling nauseous of the chemo
They took a picture of the
Hospital and refrigerator of what was open to them as patients and they could help themselves
It was rather it was rather disgusting actually and for that to be pushed by a medical establishment and is
It's
Mail practice. So it's a crazy so but there are some things that you can do a serious
complications in this chapter you'll read about some
Things that have been helpful with cacaxia that severe weight loss when a person is deteriorated quickly
um and
Some other frequently asked questions that you'll find in this section. So hopefully this will be helpful for you
All right, I will see you soon with the next section